don't follow what most people do because
you don't want the results that most
people get the average person is obese
likely to be divorced and has less than
1K in the bank it feels safe to do what
everyone else is doing but it's actually
a terrible decision it's like the best
way to guarantee to not have the life
that you want is to do what everyone
else is doing a lot of people have many
voices that they hear that they feel are
judging them right they have their
friends they have their uncle they have
their siblings they have their cousins
co-workers whatever I think I had just
one voice imagine how much you care
about your mother's opinion and your
father's opinion and all of those other
people and now imagine that there's
literally only one I had just a father
his approval was literally everything
and he disapproved of the path that I
wanted to take in my life and so I think
a lot of these mental faculties are
these little Frameworks or these isms
just came from like how can I combat
this incredibly booming voice in the
background the craziest thing was at the
moment that my father was most proud of
me and he approved of my life the most
was when I was the saddest and so that's
when I was like maybe his approval isn't
the right way to feel good about life